vous voyez ces arbres et sap ce qui va
se passer
ils savent que quelqu'un va mourir la
première fois que j'ai vu marc potsdam
j'ai pensé qu'il ressemblait à une photo
dans un magazine dans votre âme en poste
de l'ump comme s'il était sorti d'un
rêve où rien n'avait jamais mal tourné
on me les a prescrit vous avez une
ordonnance c'est comme ça que diable
arrive il se présente comme tout ce que
vous avez toujours voulu c'est très bien
servi une entrée fracassante en
résolvant une grosse affaire est un
braqueur de banques pourquoi si vous
m'aider à faire tomber ce braqueur qu'en
faisant ça je crois un sacré gros risque
les gros risque rapporte gros il joue
avec ses rêves elle joue avec sa vie
j'ai un boulot chez une famille j'ai
besoin de toi
rufus green a envoyé quelqu'un voulait
ma maison la nuit dernière et tu crois
que j'y suis pour quelque chose dans
cette enveloppe il ya 6000 $ pour toi je
ne veux plus jamais revoir
sale traître tu la mise ensemble la
terre vous battre tient pas en enfer
avec
à midi mercredi 1er juillet bof si sean
sur job